Samuel
[Music]
make sure she gets it okay night doing
I'm the driver you called it a coma girl
right not a girlfriend man Oh credit
card was invalid give yourself a nice
step I heard about these I've never seen
one before
Helen that you have you're not gonna ask
me if she got home okay okay I'm gonna
need anything you might have used to
record what you did here tonight
get up you know what nice nose my name
is Amy give me a left hand it was a Star
Trek very good five stars for Amy hey
you should let somebody else do this
like who anybody you're right I guess
anybody could do it but nobody does mile
that's great yeah he's helping all these
random people stay off the radar
they killed my friend so I'm gonna kill
each and every one of them the only
disappointment is that I only get to do
it once it's mistake to go to war with
him you your father your mommy just
didn't tell you
on your security you're lucky they'll
give you the opportunity to do the right
thing
this ain't one of those times
well not one one
why are you Jackie Chan
[Music]